I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense
chimpanzees 99 and a half percent
identical DNA yeah yeah so why do they
have every muscle and every bone in the
same place that we do and they're
comfortable you cross your legs they're
comfortable crossing their legs sitting
there and leaning on the thing they have
a niche they scratch it you want to call
they call okay except they like termites
and weird stuff too okay I'm gonna ask
you what she's going out of it so so the
urge and this is our ego doing this the
urge is to say what a difference that
one and a half percent makes oh it may
be as low as 1% but it's small I don't
remember the exact number but it's what
a difference that one person it makes we
have civilization and the smartest
chimpanzee can stack boxes to reach a
banana our toddlers can figure that out
I've seen young children stack things
well okay so maybe allow me to pose you
this question maybe the difference
between the human and the chimpanzee at
the 1% DNA is the same small difference
as between stacking boxes to reach a
banana and the Hubble Space Telescope
you're saying no come on how could what
do you say
obviously the telescope is much more
advanced than a monkey chimp figuring
out to stack box up you tell me you're
tend to say that okay now here's the
thought experiment imagine enough oh now
here here's a simple sentence ready okay
Danika I hear you're flying back to LA
tomorrow you catch up a plane you fly
United out of Newark or wherever you
land five hours later and you have a
dinner engagement with friends at your
favorite restaurant okay to use nothing
in that sentence that would make sense
to a chimpanzee what is an airplane
what is you know 10 o'clock in the
morning what is it in restaurant what
they the food just comes to you
what what is that where did it come from
why oh you have a whole supply chain
from farms and then the chip would have
no idea and that is the simplest
sentence you would utter in the day yeah
okay now imagine a life form and ambien
even I don't care some life form that is
1% beyond us in DNA then we are beyond
the chimp the smartest of us would be
brought forth by this species and
they'll say but the role Stephen Hawking
forward and say this one is slightly
smarter than all the other humans
because he can do astrophysics
calculations in his head like little
Timmy over here who just came home from
alien preschool Oh Timmy isn't that key
you just derive principles of calculus
put it on the refrigerator
sonic Oh their simplest thoughts would
be in yeah conceivable yeah to the most
brilliant human beings at only 1%
difference in DNA suppose there are 5%
10% 50% a hundred percent so I will not
walk forward and say look how smart we
are I will not do that
I rather wallow in how smart
we're not relative to how smart we could
be now we have an advantage because we
communicate you can benefit from
calculations done by engineers and
physicists who came before you to drive
a car fast
you don't have to invent that yourself
there are books
hmm Kindles today and that pass that
information forward Isaac Newton
invented calculus basically on a dare
and he did it before he turned 26 just
by the way by the way by the way so we
get to bankroll his
his advances and then they think of his
rungs on a ladder he built that with
that run right there now I can climb up
step on that and put in the next ladder
rung on the ladder and then someone
after me and someone after them so our
our species collectively may be able to
transcend itself transcend the
individual
[Music]